This problem we're going to start of with a template
for a recursively generated graph. If the template says if I
want one node, it'll just return a single node. For
other values, make a G1 and a G2 that are half
the size. And then we make log n connections between
G1 and G2 by picking a random point and connecting with
a random node, another random node. And connecting with a random
node etc. And then return. So this has the recurrence relationship
that only have one node with zero edges. And if
we have n nodes, we get 2 times the number of
nodes we have for a graph of half the size
plus big theta of log n. And so what we want
you to do is to solve this recurrence. But we
are going to do this one little differently, than some of
our previous homework assignments. Instead of a multiple choice question, we
want you to explain how to actually solve this. So below
there's a form link, and at that link you'll see
this question restated. We want you to do is wirte up
your answer, post your response to the form, get the link
for your answer. And then insert it here. I'll give an
example to make this more clear. So here's the question on
the forum. And you should write up your answer. Some possible
answers might be that T of n is theta log n,
theta n log n, theta n, theta n squared. There's any
other function. And then you should explain why you've
answered like this. Or just submit your answer. Hit
the link button. Copy out the link. Now, if
you've copied the link, paste it into the box here.